[Music]
every decade has its Vivid highlights
and low lights the 80s more so than most
it was a decade we viewed through the
world of our TV
screens and sometimes we couldn't
believe our own eyes very first national
over winre sh I went Bonkers this is
unreal oh my God like this is the
craziest sexiest thing I ever saw big
events or shared events the world
stopped that day it was all over the
news who shot
Jr I'm talking about world changing in
this show we're focusing on the good
times the wow moments that were
discussed around water coolers and in
the'80s there was a lot to talk about
that was something to remember that's
for sure in a decade packed with
indelible memories ten defined the word
Unforgettable but only one can top them
[Music]
all at number 10 a wild ride into some
late night
[Music]
Shenanigans I enjoy seeing a grown man
do that occasionally go ahead in the
early 80s a new generation of standup
Comics scum bucket we're Breaking All
the
Rules at the head of the back David
Letterman but Letterman had taken over a
bigger stage an idiosyncratic late night
talk show what made him different in a
nutshell Anything could happen you know
and that was the kind of show it was
Letterman really broke the mold in terms
of a late night
[Music]
host at the same time another comedian
was inventing an entire new reality his
name was Andy Kaufman men everybody
sing Andy coffin would just screw with
the audience's sense of reality I
thought this was going to be real
contest and I think you are making joke
it was really hard to distinguish what
was a joke and what wasn't in July 1982
Letterman and Kaufman's Worlds Collide
in an explosive encounter that changes
TV history ididentification get thees
out
that night Letterman's other guest was
Jerry Lawler a future WWE Hall of Fame
wrestler and a man who Kaufman had a
very public Grudge
with Kaufman had been causing huge
controversy wrestling women as part of
his avantgard comedy
[Music]
Act 3 months earlier Lawler had publicly
challenged kman to fight a man Jerry
Lawler was a big actual wrestler like a
legitimate scary opponent for him and it
didn't go very
[Applause]
well Kaufman is out cold stretched off
apparently unconscious with a neck
injury Kaufman agrees to face off with
Lawler again this time on Letterman's
show
tonight for the first time on network
television they meet face to
face things escalated and they started
insulting each other I could have sued
you for everything you're worth and I
didn't because that's I'm not that kind
of a guy yeah you know what uh what kind
of a guy are
you not I'll just be over here we're
going to appuse here for station
identification and get the hoses
out
[Music]
and when Jerry Lawler hit him it was
like whoa what just happened this is
crazy I was of course on stage on set on
camera in it and saying oh my God what
you know I is this show is this What's
Happening Here is security going to
break this because Kaufman loses it you
are full of my friend I will sue you for
everything you have you hear
[Laughter]
[Applause]
me
everybody was like stunned you had to
ask somebody else did you watch
Letterman last night yeah I did did you
see Andy what was going on there
everyone's like was that real not real
they go it was real it was real well
that about wraps this segment up I want
to thank my guests Mr Lawler Jerry thank
you very much for being here caufman
Lawler and Letterman all maintained the
brawl was entirely unscripted no one
knew for certain at the time but what we
do know is that tragically less than 2
years later Andy Kaufman's life was was
struck short by lung cancer then in 1994
10 years after Kaufman's death Jerry
Lawler finally admitted that the feud
was staged that's how great of an actor
Jerry Lawler is I said to you fooled
everyone but there's one final twist in
a 2019 podcast the now retired King of
the late night talk show finally admits
he was also in on the setup he he would
say here's what's going to happen and
then Jerry Lawler will come out and
we're going to get into an argument and
then he's going to hit me and then I'll
go down and that'll be the segment and I
said okay and and then it happens and
even though I knew roughly what was
going to happen it was still oh my God
he wasn't
[Music]
kidding look it got everybody talking
and 30 years later we're still talking
about
it imagine the reaction of Music
executive
when a couple of Headstrong artists
decided to mash up their resped musical
genres risking commercial disaster meet
our moment number
[Music]
nine in 1985 Run DMC are on a mission to
break down barriers and bring hipop to a
mainstream audience see people thought
Hip Hop's for black people and rock is
for white people hey this is a rock and
roll Museum you guys don't belong in
here Rick Ruben run dmc's record
producer comes up with a wild way to
shake things up it's his idea to have
rund DMC cover Aeros Smith's Walk This
Way it was an incredible Game Changer
you got to remember like this was a rock
and roll band this was a hip-hop
band
[Music]
despite obvious musical differences the
two bands Bond and cut a staggering
crossover
version but in the mid 80s it's not
enough to just be heard you also have to
be
seen they need airtime on MTV but
there's a big problem MTV in its
earliest years focused only on their
Target demographic which they envisioned
as young white males who were into rock
music it occurred to me having watched
MTV over the last few months I'm just
flawed by the fact that there's so few
black artists featured on it why is that
I I wish that MTV would have taken the
lead
sooner but it was that interview that
made us realize we have to move
forward MTV broadens its playlist of
black artists but hip-hop remains
strictly off
limits to break down the remaining walls
Run DMC needs a knockout video I had to
make this great that they had no choice
of airing it he said I'm going show the
world their problem they put up walls
that don't need to be
there music has no boundary a good song
is a good song in the summer of 1986 the
bands reunite on a New Jersey film set
we built a wall in the center of the
stage man yo what's up with this and and
set up the whole scenario arol Smith was
annoyed at Run DMC because their noise
was coming through their
[Music]
side you know it's funny uh him trying
to break through the wall I thought it
was great you know I think he thought he
was going to get through it in one
[Music]
shot the idea is simple the message
Crystal Clear and at last
MTV gets it on July 3rd 1986 MTV Premier
the video bringing hip hop to the
mainstream and changing popular music
forever oh God I think we played it
every hour I think it was um nonstop
airing you know MTV was a foundation of
exposing hip-hop to the world because it
put us in everybody's living
room it was revolutionary and
groundbreaking and Innovative I'm
talking about world
changing now you might be asking
yourself how did we arrive at our top 10
good question we recruited eight
brilliant cultural historians who ranked
the highlights from 10 to one but
carefully considering two factors 80s
wow their importance at the time and
impact their legacy today our number
eight celebrates a moment when America
gave a mass salute to some men and women
who had served the nation very
[Music]
[Laughter]
well in 1983 Mash's theme tune rings out
for the last time this marks the end of
an era and not just in terms of
TV immediately to admitting we all
wanted to watch the last episode of mash
we all loved
Mash during the 80s you would be
hardpressed to find a better crafted
show than Mash I I just feel very lucky
that I have a chance to go in every day
and do work that I can be proud of 13
years earlier Mash began Life as a
controversial movie a film that grappled
with the aftermath of the Vietnam War
America was pretty burned out on Vietnam
and almost didn't even want to talk
about it didn't want to look at it
fusing comedy and drama around medics in
the earlier less divisive Korean War
Mash held up a mirror to the nation's
mixed feelings about armed conflict Mash
was a way to look at a clean war and
look at good guys doing good things in a
war saving
people but by the early 80s Mash's
anti-establishment Vibe is out of step
with America's rediscovered military
swagger it was the end of something that
had started in another decade that was
very different from the ' 80s that
embodied a lot of different values than
the 80s and there was something about
letting that
go Mash's time was up but the producers
wanted to ensure it went out with a
[Music]
bang
four oh
no next Monday night Mash 4077 will fold
up their tents and head for home the the
announcement of Mash's final episode
creates a massive outpouring of
affection for the show main reason I
like to watch it because of the
portrayal of the characters 8:30 I'm
going to be there watching it I remember
the very last episode and and I remember
what a big deal it
[Music]
was on February 28th
1983 a 2hour special brings the show and
the war it portrayed to a heartfelt
close the cast's poignant onscreen
farewells seem to speak for the nation a
nation that also needed to say
goodbye look I know how tough it is for
you to say goodbye so I'll say it miss
you I always ask people this question
tell me what the last line of mash is I
let you not and the last line of
dialogue is actually
what and then you get the goodbye and
the rocks that you can see from the
helicopter cuz BJ who would never say
goodbye has spilled it out in the rocks
at the end I think that's one of the
reasons that we loved Mash is because
match always surprised us nearly 106
million Americans watch the finale a
record for a TV drama that still stands
today they honored themselves and the
audience and it deserved to win all
records so far we've had a meltdown at
number 10 broken down walls at number
nine and broken records at number eight
but our number seven helped change the
way we watch
TV cynics have said that bad news sells
best because good news is no news but
our number seven revolves around bad
news that became good news and kept the
world watching a new fangled kind of TV
network and in West Texas tonight The
Saga of little Jessica McClure has been
going on since midm morning yesterday
yesterday the 18-month-old girl fell
through an 8-in opening into a well in
Midland Texas oh we were so we were so
scared Jessica is trapped in a dry well
22 ft deep and encircled by thick
rock mom was so upset and it was just
like is she going to be
okay baby Jessica's distraught teenage
parents chip and can do nothing
but watch on
helplessly
NBC's Dan Molina is standing by now in
Midland with an update on that dramatic
situation the rescue effort has been
mounting every hour eventually reaching
strong I was seven at the time you can
kind of almost put yourself in her shoes
and be like oh my God could I fall down
a well could that happen to
me as Rescuers command deer a large RI
rig to dig a precarious 28t hole
parallel to the well TV networks
scramble to cover the ongoing
rescue among them a struggling new 247
News Channel called CNN whose fate will
become inextricably linked to Jessica's
story Jessica can be heard to call to
her mother she has been singing and
occasionally
crying she said she hungry she hasn't
had anything to eat or drink for more
than a day but medical personnel on the
scene say they don't want anything pass
down to her for fear she'll
choke after 48 Hours Jessica is still
trapped all the world can do is watch
wait and fear for the worst the
nail-biting tension continues as
Rescuers get Ever So Close CNN's 247
coverage helps transform baby Jessica's
plight from personal tragedy into
National
Obsession Ted Turner the guy who started
CNN realized that people wanted to watch
the news when they wanted to see it not
when it comes on at 7:00 on the network
we are told that there are now uh
lowering an engineer into that
hole all the networks cover the ongoing
rescue but CNN now owns the
story for the latest let's switch again
live to our exhaust at CNN Personnel on
the scene here again correspondent Tony
Clark Tony you can see uh the same thing
we're seeing here The Rescuers are all
standing around the the shaft they're
looking down there is a par ofic
Millions watch as the rescue
unfolds I mean literally I was up for
two days cuz I just got so involved like
they got to get Jessica Baby Jessica get
baby out of there
please after after 58 hours trapped in a
well we're obviously still waiting it's
time is running out to save Baby
Jessica it looks like they're bringing
her up right now we're seeing a lot of
activity the ropes are being pulled up
uh Jessica's mother is is running over
to the area where she is this is the
moment that we've been waiting
for you can see the enthusiasm you can
hear the Applause as Jessica is is
brought out has taken a long time
everyone cried when they pulled Baby
Jessica out it was such a
[Music]
[Applause]
relief the story of Baby Jessica became
extremely personal for so many people
even the president and Nancy Reagan are
caught up in the moment they call
Jessica's parents from the hospital
where the first lady has been admitted
for a biopsy there Ronald Reagan and
ny's on the other phone hello hello Mrs
dragon how are you feeling well I want
you to know that I was supposed to get
ready for the operation the next morning
and I I couldn't do it until I sat there
and watched her come
up well we appreciate it I think you
must be aware by now that everybody in
America uh became Godfathers and
godmothers of of Jessica we'd all been
[Music]
praying
CNN's coverage marks a turning point in
news media it is the moment when people
began to expect even demand what we take
for granted today instant updates at the
touch of a button I don't know how to
say thank you
enough 1972 was the last time we walked
on the moon ever the American Space
Program went into hibernation but like
so many things it came roaring back in
the 80s our number six
[Music]
4 3 2 1 and LIF on January 28th
1986 the space shuttle Challenger
exploded upon liftoff the whole world
watched and the whole world
grieved but a very different emotion
attended the shuttle's maiden voyage 5
years earlier we have no down link
April 12th
1981 the space shuttle Colombia's launch
has already been delayed 2 days due to
technical problems and no one wants to
think of the disastrous consequences of
failure well Sam it's had its problems a
few years behind schedule and more than
a few dollars over budget the shuttle is
intended to be a game changer the
world's first reusable space
vehicle this thing was unbelievable what
it could do you know laun like a rocket
and land like an airplane nothing before
could ever do that this is shuttle
launch control at tus 20 minutes and
holding but that's only if it can get
off the
ground mile after mile of campers and
crowds well over a million people a
nation's hopes and prayers fix on
Astronaut John Young and Robert
krippin everybody here anxiously hoping
waiting watching 35 seconds all they're
thinking about is the word lift off 25
seconds launch
sequer 5 four we've gone for main engine
start we have main engine
start first a shuttle and the shuttle
has cleared the
tower the sense of being an American at
that particular time was
prideful United States of
America so it's kind of like Hey we're
back in
business what help was something to
remember that's for sure America's back
in space finally and I hope we're there
to
stay for the watching Millions it's an
inspiring moment heralding a new age of
space
travel especially for an aspiring
astronaut if you would have told me hey
you're going to fly on that spaceship
someday no way but that's the spaceship
I flew on moving one of his shoulder
straps out of the way there I got to fly
on space shuttle Columbia on my first
flight okay we copy
that the shuttle blazed a trail
encouraging a new generation of Space
Explorers to boldly go where no one has
gone before it was in really an amazing
[Music]
accomplishment
next the burning question that was on
everyone's lips in the summer of 1980
it's all everybody was talking about and
can you believe
[Music]
it so far we've seen tragedy averted
surreal talk show theater and the last
call for a beloved TV show our number
five had the highest rated 80s Factor
the shot literally heard around the
world
[Music]
who shot Jr who shot Jr who shot Jr who
shot
Jr who's
[Music]
there his wife probably did it I have a
hunted brother did I would he's a son of
Dallas is America's leading Prime Time
soap opera and actor Larry Hagman makes
arch villain Jr Ying the man that
everybody loves to
hate Harry this is what I want you to do
close down that
field that's right the reason he became
a main character in the show was because
Larry Hagman played him well you didn't
think oh that's Larry Hagman you got
that's Jr Jr was was sort of our first
reality show villain in a
[Music]
way but in 1980 a suddenly extended run
means the show's writers have to create
a new season finale in a hurry they were
sitting in the writer room they were
going what are we going to do what are
we going to do and somebody just said
well let's shoot
somebody and then unanimously everybody
went it's got to be Jr at the last
minute unsure of exactly who will shoot
Jr the writers decide to by Time by
building in a cliffhanger they didn't
know who did it at the end of that
season they they didn't care they said
we have all summer now to try and figure
out who did it and why but no one
realizes that this writers room creative
block will unleash a global Obsession
they have now been labeled the shots
heard round the world who shot JR says
time is the most tantalizing secret
since watergate's deep throat you heard
discussed on kids shows it was on the
radio the DJs would banter about it
it was everywhere The Producers realized
they've created the ultimate hook for
the next season and to keep everyone
including the cast guessing they even
film multiple versions of the big reveal
we were the last people in the world to
know the cast of Dallas Larry didn't
know who shot him who done it I don't
know who did it you must know I don't I
swear I don't uh I they they're not
going to tell
me in November 198
after 8 months of feverish speculation
the nation is on Tiner hooks
anticipating the big reveal all of
America was like tuned into finding out
who killed Jr that hour of Dallas
everybody said shut up we're watching no
eating don't crinkle the paper if you
still don't know you may not want to
watch in the next 20 seconds especially
you on the west coast if you want to
wait and see it in just a bit here it
is it was you
Kristen the shooter turns out to be
Kristen Jr's mistress who is also his
sister-in-law of course she was the
world finally exhales after holding its
breath for most of 1980 and who shot Jr
sets a precedent for season
finales I can't remember another time
that there was a gigantic Cliffhanger
that the entire world was tuned into to
see how it was going to resolve yeah
he's just about the best liar I ever met
with the exception of myself of course
the Yang to Jr's Yin in the80s was a
very real person who was also self-made
rich and Powerful only she used her
unique talents for
[Music]
good this is Eyewitness New I'm Sam D at
the start of the 1980s whatever Channel
you tune into well the number one
television show TV news and talk shows
look very
similar that's night news for this
Tuesday night I'm Tom broa good night
from all of us at NBC
news but an ambitious young reporter
from rural Mississippi is out to change
that Oprah Winfrey and the Eyewitness
News Team Oprah Winfrey had landed her
first job as a TV anchor at just 19
years old president CER announced just
this morning becoming the youngest woman
to Anchor the news at the Nashville TV
station and the only african-amer
her personable style wins admirers in
the audience but not TV bosses she is
demoted to daytime for being what her
male bosses call um too emotional I have
a gift I understand that it's a gift to
be myself in front of the camera I am as
comfortable in front of the camera as I
am breathing in 1984 Oprah takes over a
low rated half hour morning talk show am
Chicago and the emotion she showed too
much of on news becomes a talk show
secret
[Music]
weapon I'm trying not to let my feelings
show here in the year or two that she
was on AM Chicago she took the ratings
from I think what was like zero it was
like last place to you know the
[Music]
top less than a year later they named
The Show for her start out with a
smile and once opra starts beating
daytime talk show King Phil Donahue in
Chicago's TV ratings the stage is set
for Oprah's National
syndication hello
everybody
thanks thank you I'm Oprah Winfrey and
welcome to the very first national Oprah
Winfrey
Show Oprah and her creative team know
this first episode will be Mak or break
they are desperate to make a big
celebrity
Splash Oprah who are the guests for the
first
show is it Mother
Teresa is it the pop is it gr Garbo but
with no takers Oprah's solution is an
intuitive master class in connecting
with a mass audience a class act that
sets Oprah apart from the competition
that will soon have no hope of competing
we we decided to do what we do best and
that is a show about and with everyday
people sure the celebrities are great
later on but you have to make that
connection with the audience regular
people being on stage talking about
world issues and was very before her
time Oprah takes a record 48% of the
afternoon audience but two things have
bugged me for years the first my thighs
the second like what woman in America
didn't want to hear that at that point
it was like oh my gosh thank you for
saying that and she's determined to have
their thoughts feelings and aspirations
aired on national TV Oprah is a real
woman a real person Oprah is a friend
and I like to say that Oprah you are
beautiful Oprah's capacity to be as one
with her audience opens the way for a
whole new Dialogue on daytime
TV honestly I feel like Oprah changed
The Narrative of what black women are
and who they are people started seeing
us in a more professional light she
showed vulnerability but she also showed
strength at the same time and I just
think that that's really
dope
OA Oprah's National TV debut marks the
start of something big really big the
Oprah Winfrey Show will run for 25
unbroken years and become the foundation
for her enduring Empire of empathy it
was really revolutionary for daytime TV
thank you
America Oprah's is a pretty tough act to
follow but our top three is going to do
just
[Music]
[Applause]
that so I know we've missed some iconic
moments of the 80s and here's why they
revolved around tragedy not Triumph the
Challenger explosion the attempted
assassination of Ronald Reagan the
actual assassination of John Lennon
today we're here to remember the good
times and that is front and center as we
approach our top three like our next
moment when a withdrawn publicity shy
introvert transformed into a world
Superstar all right the only part of
that sentence it's actually true is the
Superstar part
[Music]
men have been string their funky stuff
ever since rock and roll began but women
were different and usually portrayed
only as passive objects of Desire when
in 1981 Punk singer Wendy O Williams of
the plasmatics dared to be sexually
suggestive on stage she was
arrested but but 3 years later at the
1984 VMAs one woman would confront these
double standards head on we wanted the
bmas to be the anti-g grams and so the
more outrageous stuff that happened the
better dressed in a wedding gown with a
17t cake behind her Madonna seizes her
moment she went down as she started to
roll around and her dress started to
come up I wasn't even sure what I was
doing you know I just kind of went for
it
[Music]
and she kept the ring and rolling going
on her Blockbuster virgin tour she was
this unfettered expression of female
sexuality oh my God like this is the
craziest sexiest thing I ever saw and I
was like
wow the fact that people are interested
in what I'm doing it only pushes me more
to you know keep coming up with new and
interesting ways to express
myself parents May hate Madonna's
particular form of self-expression but
for the nation's teenagers an icon and
yes role model is born I like her
attitude and the way she presents
herself she doesn't like let anybody
step on
her I wasn't allowed to like Madonna but
I loved
Madonna
it was a harbinger of what this artist
was going to do mainstream America can't
hold back the tide Madonna's Sensational
performance inspires female artists
everywhere to own their sexuality and
create their own empowerment and the
world would never be the same again a
woman can go up there look like a rock
star but then be extremely feminine and
and I just I I thought she was
amazing all the world's a stage but
sometimes the stage becomes the entire
world and our number two moment is truly
momentous both for the cause and the
band who stole the
[Music]
show July 13th 1985 the curtain Rises on
one of the biggest pop concerts in the
history of Music a devastating famine in
Ethiopia has inspired Irish rocker Bob
gelof to Stage a worldwide concert to
raise awareness and raise
money
hi it's 12 noon in London 7:00 a.m. in
Philadelphia and around the world it's
time for Live Aid this mega concert was
designed to reach a mega audience it was
broadcast all over the world I think
about 2 billion or more more people
watched and tuned in it felt like
something incredibly special was
happening and despite performances by
the likes of Sting rund DMC and Black
Sabbath the cash just isn't coming in
get your money out now and phone up and
give us the
money live a needs a big hitter
performance next up 70's band Queen but
with allegations that the band is burnt
out and that Freddy's personal life is
falling apart the big question is can
Queen
deliver Freddy Mercury had that audience
right where he wanted them from the
moment he got out there on
[Music]
stage there was such a a joy there was
so much energy in that
[Music]
performance they blew most everybody out
of the
[Music]
water
everybody
[Music]
we I had helped put Queen on stage and I
was standing in the
wind and when he did Radio Gaga seemed
that the tension in the air had changed
it seemed like gravity had dropped or
something you look at at that sea of
people and they're all pumping their
hands in unison it's I mean even just
watching it on TV and not being there
you feel you know goosebumps watching it
when you watch that performance it's
like wow it's considered one of the
greatest live performances in rock and
roll live a has finally arrived and the
rock legend is born Freddy's voice is
dubbed the note that's heard around the
world and the cash donations flood
[Applause]
in it was a Mythic performance that you
knew was Mythic when you were seeing it
and that doesn't happen very
[Music]
often just chill inducing to watch
Queen's performance is the turning point
for Live Aid which went on to raise over
$125 million and set a trend for big
charitable concerts in Aid of the needy
a trend that continues to this
day it's been an amazing journey and we
are nearly at the summit so far we've
met three queens Oprah Madonna and the
band which I think is a hint for our
number one coming
[Music]
up
we've witnessed some cultural weddings
in our top 10 hip hop and heavy metal
Oprah tying the knot with the entire
civilized World Madonna and her 17t tall
cake but the wedding of the80s combin
all of the themes of our water cooler
moments here's our number
[Music]
one November 17th 198
19-year-old Diana Spencer is returning
from work when she is besieged by
reporters everyone wants to know if
Prince Charles has popped the all
important question K is there any
possibility of any announcement of your
marriage in the near future can you tell
me can you tell me there's any
possibility I'm not going to say
anything great Prince Charles did give
us a hint himself he said we wouldn't
have to wait too long on February 24th
19 1981 the engagement is finally made
official the whole world is watching and
now contracts wedding fever well the
guest list for The Royal Wedding reads
like uh who's who of beautiful and
powerful
people the British proved once again
that when it comes to popping
circumstance they have no peers We As
Americans as a nation we all kind of
wanted to be looking in the windows uh
and watch what was going on and be a
part of that
somehow but just one thing becomes the
center of everyone's
Obsession who did the dress what the
dress look like it was better than whoa
Jr it was just a great secret Diana
chooses British designers David and
Elizabeth Emanuel to create the
dress Lady Diana turned up it was a big
surprise and she said you and David do
me the honor of making my wedding dress
but we have to keep it secret nobody
must know I think even the palace
underestimated the
interest we became aware of
photographers and they were leasing
Apartments opposite us with their
longrange cameras as speculation about
the dress reaches fever pitch the
emanuels are forced to make elaborate
backup plans every night before we went
home the dress went into this huge metal
case and it was guarded what we did do
just as a bit of an insurance policy was
to create another dress in case it got
out we hoped she'd never have to wear it
but it was a different style then we
realized people also going through our
rubbish bins so we started laying false
trails and Gathering bits of different
color Fabrics to put in our
bins the emanuels managed to keep the
real dress under wraps and on July 29th
1981 750 million people around the globe
gathered to watch the wedding of the
decade good evening now for a little
while a respit from reality it's fairy
tale
[Music]
time the world stopped that day I mean I
don't remember anybody who wasn't
watching at just after 10:00 a.m. Diana
starts the procession to St Paul's
Cathedral at her side her father the El
Spencer and the wedding dress that has
been a carefully guarded
secret it's a glass coach and all you
saw was the Hest
material here she
comes got a job getting all those yards
of so and what a dream she looks what a
dream she looks she looks like an angel
and and it took my breath away like it
really took my breath away the dress is
made of yards of ivory pure silk Taff
her and if you asked a little girl to
draw a princess I think she draw a dress
just like that as a young girl it's like
oh is this what it's like to marry
Prince Charming there she goes up the
steps her look our affection for her
globally it's one of those moments that
marked that time period it was one of
those events that you will never forget
and everybody celebrated it I Diana
Francis hi Diana Francis take thee
Charles Philip Arthur Jo I could only
imagine what that must have been like
for her kind of being slightly obscure
and then being thrown into the world's
complete Spotlight I pronounce that they
be man and wife together the wedding of
Prince Charles and Lady Diana combines
the essence of the80s zeitgeist a
compelling empathetic personality a
cliffhanger surprise and a unique news
event that transforms a moment into an
enduring memory and our number one it
was giving us something that we
culturally thought we needed and really
wanted which was
glamour it was an exaggeration and sort
of a display of wealth and aristocracy
that you only saw in
the80s
[Applause]
[Music]